let's get to the phones the phones are
hot 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we're going to take our first
caller now from the nine zero one area
code caller what's your name and where
you calling from today my name is Logan
I'm corny mmm you still with us there
Logan
David David yeah can you hear me we can
barely hear you what's on your mind
today Logan I want to ask how do you
feel about Trump possibly moving the US
Embassy to from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
I'm against it I'm against it I think
that it's that that's the type of
unilateral move and I mentioned this
when he announced that David Friedman
would be the ambassador to Israel I am
against that I believe that that is a
that is if that's something that is
going to happen it should only happen if
and when it is negotiated as part of
some broader agreement for for peace in
the israeli-palestinian conflict I think
that the unilateral move of the embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem which is not
recognized internationally as the
capital of Israel it is recognized
within Israel as the capital but not
internationally I think that it's a
disastrous idea well I'm really
surprised that I thought you feel that I
know that you're bait that you disagree
with with trample on a lot of things now
virtually everything but I do know that
you seem to be pretty Pro pro-israel so
it surprises me that you that you think
about that what what essentially I'm
what specifically have I said that would
make you think I would support moving
the embassy to Jerusalem well I guess I
guess I guess I just first thought that
you were always pretty pretty pro-israel
and I did I didn't realize that I I just
thought you know there have been a lot
of people who have really have been like
people in in Israel who have really
wanted Trump to move the embassy who
just in I know that you that you have a
lot of ties to Israel and stuff like
that and so it just it really surprises
me what what do you mean what kind of
ties do I have to Israel for
nope you got in and well I'm everything
ties but I know that you really that you
have we support them a lot a lot issues
right well are there any issues in
particular that you could point to where
you would say I support is I'm just
trying to figure out what you're talking
about
well I'm are within different issues
that they directly support them to
saying that that year that usually the
Israel should be certain nation that in
that kinetic no and that Israel should
be able to determination I thought that
it would be and when you said in when I
purchased it I thought you would that
you would think that the appropriate us
could move the embassy but mmm thank you
I really appreciate it
alright so it sounds like yourself
because I believe as well it sounds like
you're saying because I believe Israel
is a country that exists that I would
support the moving of the embassy to
Jerusalem right well I would think that
because it because this is really use a
Jerusalem as their main capital about
that I just I just thought because many
people are heavily inside Israel who do
just I I don't know I I just always
thought that you would suit you have
supported up all right well listen I
don't and I'm on record as having said
that so I get I'm glad we've cleared up
a misconception if nothing else I think
it's also important to point out that
Donald Trump is and as Adam it now about
his support about moving the embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem and that was
about a week ago that he said we'll see
so maybe things have changed now but
yeah he's not all about that anymore
alright well Logan glad I was able to
dispel a false notion that you had about
my views really really appreciate the
call